[Applause]
[Music]
kelly clarkson and ariana grande sing
each other's hits
but they don't exactly nail it i'm
nervous about it the pop stars and their
fellow coaches on the voice john legend
and blake shelton face off on jimmy
fallon's new nbc game show that's my jam
in a teaser clip ari and blake take on
kelly and john going lyric for lyric in
a hilarious game of slay it don't spray
it the rules are simple spin the wheel
and sing whatever song it lands on you
must sing it word for word miss a lyric
well you get sprayed
easy enough right kelly and john kick
things off with the talk show host
singing ari's hit break free wait is it
take it
how's it gonna happen
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah things are off to a solid start but
it didn't take long for kelly to
eventually stumble over the words
[Music]
[Applause]
next up ari who felt pretty confident
after spinning the wheel and landing on
kelly's song stronger who's gonna sing
it all right
all right ariana's gonna sing this one
okay here we go
stronger by kelly clarkson whenever
you're ready i just want to point out
that like her most famous songs we did
not go with
you
honestly things were looking pretty good
for the 28 year old god as a woman
singer
until they weren't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but this isn't the only epic showdown
between kelly and ari on the show i'm
excited y'all in a previously released
teaser clip from the episode which
premieres january 3rd jimmy tasked ari
and kelly with singing a medley of
classic hits during the show's mixtape
medley showdown segment with a spin of
the show's big wheel the two were
assigned the genre pop divas and well
fans got a real musical treat
[Music]
yeah that's ari belting out britney
spears and kelly covering shania twain
it was like so crazy but it didn't stop
there ari went on to crush a cover of
cher and whitney houston
[Music]
while kelly belted out some tony braxton
and alanis morissette
but most impressive of all was ari
singing a little celine dion no like
seriously i hope you're ready for it i
was born already
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as for the competition between kelly and
ari well back in may before season 21 of
the voice started filming e.t caught up
with a piece by p singer who said she
couldn't wait to have ari on the show
i'm a huge fan of her voice i love her
voice i've only run into her a couple
times and she's so sweet like every time
we run into each other so i'm just a fan
she syncs so beautifully and is um just
killing it still in the charts like
she's just an amazing coach like to have
on the show so i think it's going to be
really cool and fun and i like female
energy
you